very excited to welcome the two forces
behind apache hoodie
today we have venath chandar
and vanath is the vp
of apache hoodie and also
a principal engineer at confluent where
he's working on
kafka performance and stream processing
and we also have nishith who is also
um very involved in the apache hoodie
project
um he's an engineering manager at uber
and he's also a pmc
of the apache hoodie project so guys um
thanks for joining us today
yeah thanks for having us thanks for
hanging speed
so i was looking over the the hoodie
site and
um one of the things that jumped out at
me i'm always sensitive to
how a project like this um immediately
positions itself
and so i read that apache foodie ingests
and manage
storage of large analytical data sets
over distributed file systems
um what what does that mean exactly it
sort of kick us off by explaining at a
high level
what the main idea of foodie is so um
so the core business problem that hoodie
tries to solve is to
make your uh data lake much more cheaper
cheaper
much more scalable and sort of like more
capable it also brings like more
database like features uh to the data
lake
um without actually sacrificing the cost
and scalability that these
data lakes are actually great for right
so stepping
into that a little bit what
that description uh which i think can be
improved upon
is basically trying to say is we we've
tried to
build uh the core like the curl for huli
which
may helps you you know perform updates
dailies give incremental change streams
out of tables
which kind of uh are the core technical
capabilities
but also we have you know engine tools
a lot of data management tools which
actually help you
build a data lake which is sort of like
you know
a lot more cost effective as you
assuming so hoodie
as a project um you know it also aims to
it gives you the core set of like
technical capabilities like updates
deletes um and but
also provides the necessary tools and
components like congestion tool we have
an incremental etl tool
we have data management tools for
compaction we're working on clustering
data based on query patterns and stuff
we have tools that can take backup
restore of data sets
and i i could see hoodie you know
eventually adding
data monitoring capabilities uh like a
data deletion library
uh that we see that it's a common thing
across users
that usefully uh to be doing like you
know gdpr's
like privacy regulation compliant data
deletion operations
and maybe even a meta server that can
like you know give you all this
information across your ecosystem
so that's kind of like how where where
where we are going we're trying to build
stuff around the corner
that's that's a lot of stuff and um
i'm i'm excited to dig into those bits
through the conversation um now vanessa
if i recall
you might have kicked things off with a
blog post in 2016.
i think it was august 2016 about four
years ago
um on incremental processing over hadoop
um at the time did you understand like
what a big impact this could make um
i think a very technical level i i did
actually uh but not not from like
you know from industry perspective how
like
uh you know um ubiquitous
this pattern would become uh because i i
came from so the short
kind of like origin story here is that
so
my background before i came to uber was
i worked on database replication in
oracle where
you know i'm very familiar with cdc
streams and stream processing or those
things in general
then at linkedin my role was building a
key value store
so i knew databases and data application
very well and we started to build a data
like you know started to ingest data
incrementally from databases at uber and
then we
you know hit this fundamental impedances
match where
everything until that point can be done
very incrementally
except for when you try to like you know
just data onto hdfs or you know these
hardware compatible storage
uh so the technically i it was very
clear to us from the get go that if we
solve this
we are going to get back a lot of
compute resources back
uh our etls are going to be like much
much much cheaper we
weren't uh so most of that blog post
was kind of uh i was mostly writing it
for
myself to seek more uh kind of you know
industry sort of feedback because this
sort of thing hasn't been done
in the the kind of the hdfs analytics
land before
while coming from a database background
it just seemed very natural to me to do
something like that
um but we
until the the reason i think the gdpr
and the privacy law regulations that
force companies to kind of have
penalties as a percentage of their
revenue
that whole thing kind of change the
adoption curve for these technologies
um because uh before that we would see
people
who were like nodding their head oh yeah
we should do everything incrementally
uh but then the the
probably like you know think of it as an
optimization
not more like something that you need to
design your data lake far
from the ground up so i think the gdpr
uh regulations and the you know the ccpa
the privacy
law regulations uh who had a like a
massive impact
on taking these kind of technologies
mainstream i would say
and and so um nisha you were previously
a software engineer at cisco
um i think you were probably at walmart
labs around the time that
um that uh post was was first published
um how did you how did you get dragged
into apache foodie
yeah i i actually joined like right
about the time just before
the blog was published so i remember um
so i was mostly working on data
infrastructure stuff
um like a lot of low-level cassandra you
know migrating like you know
traditional oracle stuff to cassandra
and then
i was very interested in sort of like
how like the database world works and i
worked a lot about like tombstones
tunings and cassandra et cetera
and um i was i was trying to understand
and and we were also moving this data
to you know the big data back in the day
when i was working at one month
and uh to me it was very intriguing like
you know how to
sort of merge these concepts of this
database onto the
order of the big data part uh like why
can't we simply port this like what's
what's the gating factor and like i
think
right about the time when i joined like
uh you know just
just just at the time i joined like like
hoodie was like
starting off at uber and uh and like you
know folks over there talk to me about
it and i'm like yeah this is exactly
what i
think about as well like why why is it
why is it that we can't bring these
database semantics uh
you know to big data and so that's how i
got involved uh i think
uh yeah and you know when
when we first when i first joined i
think i remember we used to talk about
like why isn't anybody solving this like
like why isn't this like a solution yet
out there
and so we would question ourselves a lot
of times and that's where sort of the
the blog post came out to get more
industry like you know
feedback like like like is there nothing
out there which like does
these kinds of things um and and and
yeah and that's how you know i got like
deeply involved in the project
so i mean i think we can see how um
the the the hoodie movement or the
movement that hudi um
captured or um perhaps has has been
helpful in articulating
was kind of part of this multiple
um you know connection or or sort of
collision
of these different data things that were
happening at the time right there's
large amounts of data there's cheap
cloud storage
there's um everyone getting excited
about columnar formats um
you know if not vertica which was sort
of the the precursor then
then the more open system of formats
like parquet um at the same time
there's also this explosion and nosql
and a complete abandonment of any kind
of like acid transactions or
um you know like uh no real
sort of uh commitment to some some of
the previous database
um you know concepts that we had all
known and loved
it seems to me like hudi stepped into
this sort of an environment
and it's making sense of all of those
things
attempting to do it in some meaningful
well thought through
way based on certain design principles
that i'm sure
are are key to you guys and you'll enjoy
sharing with us is that is that a fair
sort of estimation of what was happening
in in the data world at the time
i think that's actually a very good way
to look at it really like
uh so yeah i think that that will be
that will be
like a fair a fair estimation like
before
the i didn't actually till this point uh
i'd since you heard later i didn't think
about it as a
oh yeah we didn't have no sql databases
before
uh and then you had no sql databases but
but the
the you know the analytics land hadn't
really adapted to
that sort of scale uh right yeah but
that's i think a
really good way to uh put it um
i would also add one more thing though
which is uh the rise of stream
processing
um if you think about it um so
people typically say analytic data says
data sources don't have
updates still like it shouldn't change
that was the kind of the norm
back then i i i remember
people would uh so at some point at uber
we had like
more committers like people with more
how to deep hadoop background
than i think even facebook or other
other like linkedin other
like you know kind of how do
heavyweights uh have in the industry
and then i get like constantly
challenged on hey
like this thing has been like immutable
for like ages and like you know the
company's built around it
so why why is it suddenly that we have
to solve this problem of updates and
deletes
and we actually wrestled with it a lot
internally because i was also like
okay maybe maybe it works we don't have
to generate some semantics here
but i think the clinching argument was
no matter what you do here connecting
back to stream processing right
the minute you have a derived table that
is doing a group by
uh then you can definitely implement
this
in a more incremental way that like
house you know a flink
or like a kafka stream's job using a
state store would do
right rather than the full like okay i'm
going to recompute my entire days of
counts every three hours correct you
need not do that there's a large
class of batch etls which can simply be
written in a very
incremental fashion and you can
and what we saw and a lot of people at
uber were also
tempted
just to jump in briefly i think this was
one of the main points of the post right
is that um instead of just thinking
about things that are
pure batch or pure stream um what about
this delta of
five minute increments to 60 minute
increments that
are actually like there's a lot of real
world scenarios that sort of fit into
those that that time window and
why don't we have a system that's better
suited um for the the in between land in
between true batch or true stream is
that right
right correct and a lot of ways we were
making that up because like
so so at uber right we wanted uh like
you know we we at least i think maybe
like
when we started we were like okay let's
google up data
data late we found martin followers like
description of what the architecture is
like many other people like you know him
describing what the architecture is then
actually try to implement the
architecture where you have a
you have to have a direct sort of raw
data layer which
models the operational systems above not
the business
uh like in without any semantics to it
right
then you build a buffer between these
operational systems and your analytics
pipelines on the side
but whenever people try to write etls
if you don't have this inc do this
incrementally it costs a lot of latency
for the batch jobs
then you have only two choices either
you violate the data lake architecture
by directly going to the source or some
like thing that has its own data quality
problems
uh you just like you know bypass one
layer right because that one layer adds
uh
latency or you try to pick subsets of
those etls and
simplify them and then write stream
processing jobs because
the subset of the data you want in like
real time right
so but between these you're not caught
between like a
like a rock and a hot place because you
either face data quality issues uh by
like you know bypassing all the data
quality validation checks that we do
with the raw data layer
are you are now spending you know rocks
db state stores will store
data in row based formats not columnar
formats so you are trading off
long running containers like row-based
storage at a higher cost higher premium
for latency uh while we thought okay
wait like without violating any of the
architecture anything
if all we needed to do was
in just bring the stream processing
semantics
to the the batch data if you will
because we we've gotten used to thinking
about stream and batch that way
and that's kind of where uh incremental
kind of processing really fits
and we tried to make a new term
mostly not to confuse people about
this is not stream processing in a sense
that this is um
batch processing in kind of mini micro
batches and all of our
uh kind of infrastructure that we build
in hoodie project
kind of like you know tries to realize
that uh
if you want like low latency less than
one minute real-time use case just use
like you know
copper streams of like right like that's
that's what will serve that purpose
uh if you don't care about like latency
at all stick to batch processing
but for edls are this kind of like
pipelines that
keep chugging along with new input we
believe that this is a very
powerful paradigm to express those those
etls
uh on
go ahead dishes no i was just gonna add
also like when we were doing this right
like we realized there is actually a
void
where um between this like five minute
and like
60 minutes as you put it like that if
users want
five minutes they have to go to stream
processing if users
uh and and you know if you want some of
that in between style you either have
the option of batch or stream and
like both of these options are overkills
or undertales for that solution
and as we build this then we realize
okay a lot of use cases actually
fit in between which have avoided and
they end up going to stream processing
and then
the points that minot mentioned you have
data quality issues because you are
either ingesting them into some online
store and then like backing them up
and then you can't do joins maybe
because like that's hard
uh given like you have some stuff in
online then you
probably have to curate some of your
data and put them in your online stores
so that void i feel like uh was also
something that
became more apparent
and so so then if that's the origin
story um
and if you are embracing this new form
of incremental processing
it seems like all the transaction
support all the asset support features
over the data lake sort of ultimately
were byproducts
of this um sort of architectural
paradigm
sometimes conversely i've thought of
this class of tools um
delta lake and foodie and others as
supporting trans
transactions over a data lake which
maybe is one way to think about it but
you're essentially saying that
that wasn't sort of how you came to the
table you were trying to create middle
ground
in the stream to batch processing world
um hence incremental processing
and the whole asset on transaction
support was basically a
byproduct is that is that fair
yeah i i think that that that's fair
because
you had to build if you want to build
like cdc and upsets deletes you have to
solve asset transactions anyway so
it's something that we had to solve in
version zero
i would say both came hand-in-hand like
you know because we did have
a fundamental use case at uber where we
had like lots of these
upstream changing data like trips and et
cetera uh you know which were changing
over time and then
uh you know how do you have that
represented on
the day-to-day and so we wanted
incremental processing but like
sort of acid came along pretty close
like
so um well i think that's that's very
helpful
information and sort of understanding
how hoodie came to be
and and where it sits in the ecosystem
um
let's talk about who uses hoodie
um i know that uh i saw on your
on the website on the foodie.apache.org
website um
many companies are using hoodie
alibaba tencent uber obviously
udemy i know there's others that you
can't name
financial institutions large tech
companies
even aws offers who do you support
sort of built into the aws cloud
obviously you've seen like lots of great
adoption
of the project um talk to us a little
bit about the main use cases
for hoodie and who uses it most yeah
um so i think we touched upon some of
these things so you know if you think
about it
some of the you know the fundamental
questions of like how do you manage your
data for analytics right
um so some of the questions are okay can
i get my data fast
so i can do quick analytics right um how
can i
make use of this data so is this data
schema types you know is there a
contract between
you know my upstream and my downstream
consumers so is there a schema evolution
component to it
right um can i provide isolation
guarantees between like readers and
writers
um can i uh solve this problem for
everybody downstream as we talked about
derived data sets and maybe other data
sets off of direct datasets
and can we solve these problems for uh
you know
downstream pipelines as well and then
like you know advanced stuff like you
know how do i
make my queries run faster can i
reorganize my data at rest
um to be able to suit it to more access
like better access patterns that i have
um and how can i be more cost efficient
right
um so all of these questions are like uh
you know some things that people
like you know organizations asks at the
end of the day who want to do analytics
um and those are in organizations that
we want to do it so any
any organization that is looking to
solve these problems uh you know the
interesting thing to note is
even if you're not having a specific uh
like a business use case
you know uh many of these companies run
the services which in just log data to
monitor their applications
right and at the end of the day those
those are use cases which are across any
company that is running
um some sort of service um so that
company uh has to solve these problems
at the end of the day as well
right and then we talked about gdpr and
and you know how do we make sure that
the data is correct can i restore back
to an original state
uh where you know i corrupted my data
because of some reason so all of these
like questions
who the organization's looking to answer
these questions is where
he would would be used so well i think i
think
this um this question kind of gets to
you mentioned the cost
savings as well and we actually have a
question from
a viewer rena is asking how does this
mini batch
idea help in bringing down cost
rather than the bigger batch now you
guys might might not
um want to describe foodie as a mini
batch
system because that that means could
mean something different
in this in this whole world but um i
think i understand the
the gist of rena's question right the
question is basically how does
incremental processing
lower the total cost of ownership on
running your data pipeline can you give
us some examples of that
yeah so if you if you take like a
typical batch job how people
are running kind of like etls today
let's say you have a source table
which has some events and then um
and then you are building a derived
table now where
uh you're trying to count a certain type
of event
every hour or something like that right
so now
typically what people do to lay account
for later even data
are things like that you
um write a batch job like you know
essentially
you you fully read all of the
few hours of data or the entire day's
data and you run a job
every three hours six hours whatever the
cadence be
and then fully recompute the target
partition and then keep overwriting it
right insert over right that's what most
edls do
but if you think about it from the last
time that you ran the etl
probably very little has changed in the
source data set
right so but you are recomputing and
rewriting the entire thing
so if you if you build this
kind of pipeline in a in a kind of like
a
the incremental fashion what you would
do is you would
like have a target hoodie table with you
know
a key as the event type and the hover
plus
r or something and then you would
accumulate counts
for that r in the target table and then
you would incrementally just pull new
changes that are happening in the source
for the table and then kind of compute
the delta
and then add it to the target table
right
so this as you can imagine makes your
processing
sort of uh a function of
um like the amount of total
data actually change rather than the
entire input size
right and and you can i can construe
like much harder
kind of or you know much bigger
like use cases where you don't so
the data changes for all the part like a
last hundred partitions
last 10 partitions so that bounds your
size of recompute
and depending on the size of the table
uh i
i say i would guess that today with a
batch job
you either you are over you know you're
using way more resources to recompute
are ignoring a lot of those and then you
know you have data quality fidelity
issues right
so that's that's that's kind of how how
like incremental processing can really
really help you and so key to this
is this notion of of upserts right
and upsets are complicated um
they've been complicated in databases
well just sort of by definition they're
complicated because of
race conditions and other challenges um
it seems like you guys had to tackle
this problem with upstarts
head on um and how did you how did you
think about that and how did you
ultimately design the system to be able
to handle
these these scenarios elegantly
um yeah so absurds we we
hoodies built on like kind of mvcc
principles so we we
always just version new data and then we
like at a very high level we track
the we have a transaction log which we
call the hoodie timeline
where we record every change that
happens in the database
um and and kind of like
you know we have per record metadata
about when
what what transaction a particular
record was touched in
so with these things we are able to
actually always give you the latest
uh committed version of a record um
while uh the background processes that
we have
will make sure that you know as new
versions are made old versions are
cleaned
uh if you use uh if you use the kind of
the merge and read uh
storage like table type in hoodie uh it
will make sure that the row based format
that you quickly ingested
gets merged with the base file to bound
your read amplification things like that
so honestly we followed most of
existing standard database techniques uh
and the fact that we don't uh
so you can say we
we support like a like a you know subset
of the database features right we don't
uh our rdbms like mysql does way more it
will be unfair to compare what we've
done to
kind of all the good stuff that they've
built and we don't have any foreign key
transactions we don't have like cross
table
transfer table transactions yet we are
working on them
uh but we also picked a simpler subset
of
the the database features to implement
which
makes this kind of like more more
tenable
cases are notoriously like very single
writer focus
right or you have like a like you know a
single writer
but some background process that is
doing backfill or something
some maintenance kind of thing so we we
basically solve this problem of
okay you can write and then do cleaning
and
all these async bookkeeping processes in
parallel
that concurrency control we've solved so
that that makes the system like kind of
like you know very
self-contained but also for the uh so a
lot of this
we we will see how we can tackle this
um without introducing a new kind of
like a server into the architecture
if you want to do foreign key
constraints or things like that
uh it will i think it will get like more
uh
tricky and you get into more fundamental
database challenges like
what you are alluding to but for now for
the feature sets that people
seem very happy with it's it's working
very well
yeah and aren't there there's two
niches i want you to jump in here
because i think there's there's two
different ways that
foodie handles upserts um if i'm not
mistaken
do you want to elaborate on that a
little bit more are there two there are
two modes for hoodie to run in or
explain that to me a little bit i came
across something in the documentation
but i'm trying to understand more
so i mean uh so on on the absurd spot
right like there
so it just like how a database would do
you need to
whenever you do upserts you need to
figure out where this data goes on disk
so hoodie has this pluggable index model
right so we we have an indexing
mechanism that we use
to actually do upsets while at the same
time create a balance
of how efficient can we do when we are
merging data on the plan so like for
example merge only
so um so so we we do like those kinds of
uh like you know implementations to
create this balance
but for upsert itself i mean there are
different
uh ways to begin that
the internal mechanism is is the same um
but there are different ways to do that
and you know
so hoodie provides for example three
tools the delta streamer
uh these uh sort of spark data source
way you can write like a spark dag and
then
a low level uh spark rdd-based api which
we built uh first when we started off
and then we support two different file
formats uh or other
table formats uh which is like copy on
write and like merge on read
and then um you know upsets work
differently where in copy and write we
do that in c2
where the file is rewritten and then the
nbcc
uh pattern with the timeline transaction
log guarantees what you're reading
uh versus merge on read where we log
that delta and then
whenever you read it it's merged on the
fly so that those are the
different modes which are supported
based on do you want
low latency ingestion or do you want low
latency queries
um and so you can switch between these
two
got it
and is there a is one of those usages
more common
than the other based on um the typical
use cases that you see
so we started off with a copy on right
um so that's
so you know for log append data where
you're just appending a bunch of data
which are not which is not getting
changed uh
people right now tend to use copy on
write because you
get like columnar read performance out
of the box uh
but for a lot of these like changing
data or you want really low d latency
right like you go into that five minute
ranges
then you would use more generate but um
so there isn't any
like like the copy on right is sort of
very like
battle tested been there since the
beginning uh and more generally there
are more and more new features that we
are adding there
but depending on the use case people
choose either one of those
so as a project i think overall as we go
further and further we would want to
kind of make merchant read more of the
staple
um like the table type
while uh we built a lot of the machinery
um we already built for example like if
you do merchandise you don't have to run
a separate compactor you can run a
compactor
kind of in line with the injection if
you need if you
like for example for copy and write uh
there's very little
like extra you need to do rather than
just like write a spark job and write
data
but for mergen read you need to figure
out how to run your compaction job right
so we're trying to make this more and
more easier so that people
would uh prefer to do merge and read as
the table type but we also like
our users that hey like if you pick
much and read that it's definitely more
advanced so it has like a little bit
more
bells and whistles so if you want to
keep things operationally
very very simple you can just stick to
copy and write for now
we internally try to make that barriers
go away um for the project i think
eventually if
we can make copy and write just a subset
of a merchant reconfiguration
i think that's sort of like where really
want to go
well i think that's a good segue to talk
a little bit about some of the design
principles
behind the project um how would you
articulate those
yeah so i think at the at the very core
uh level we wanted to provide two
primitives ability to change data sets
and ability to
capture data off of the the change data
of the data sets right and so we
designed it
very similar to kind of our inspiration
sort of was
uh like oltp databases how do they track
uh this sort of thing so we have like uh
like a redo log like
timeline which helps us so we're we're
design principle every we are very log
based we try to log everything
and then we try to compact the log to
make sense of things
like so there's a timeline in which um
which kind of like records uh not just
the things that happen
uh but also things that are in flight uh
that is kind of used
for coordination across the say the
background processes
and the the writers and
in in in a very uh similar way like how
say your redo logs would function and
then but
uh unlike redo logs and databases can
actually store data
uh if you in some configurations right
this mostly stores transaction handles
and kind of what data
actually changed in each transaction so
it like stores a lot more pointers
in the transaction log um and then
essentially we find so every read first
looks at the log
or like we are building a compacted
version of the log which can just
be used to you know serve uh like figure
out essentially if you say what are the
files in this partition without actually
having to list the part
partition on s3 or hdfs but essentially
the log in some form is the source of
truth every read
is fenced by the log and then that that
way we never
like you never get to query uncommitted
data
or like in-flight transactions dirty
data that they're writing
uh and things uh things like that that's
that's how the guts of it
is is designed as um our cvc is very
modeled after again like the
the database cdc products that you will
find there uh
right now we don't have all the full
capabilities like typically those
provide
like an old and a new record
for any change uh right now we just
provide you the
latest value so those are things that we
want we are
but but we have the designs to actually
support those features down the line
but more and more and more we want to
actually provide pretty much
what a database cdc would give you
uh as a chain stream out of the data set
as well so we're still
very close to kind of the the database
uh design
the other aspect is indexing so like
if you think about woody we thought
about it as okay this is like a database
but
it is a lot more scale data scale than
an oltp database because it stores
data forever uh and has like you know
and then it is columnar files but so we
essentially wanted the rights to behave
like
uh more close to a record level oltp
right
but the reads to be optimized for
analytical columnar scans
as opposed to kind of otp databases
where they're optimized for point lookup
pe kind of queries
right so that's sort of like a good good
way to
like internalize kind of the design
principle
and this is internally represented um as
park
you you chose to use parquet files
internally is that right
yeah we have uh we support party file
format but for
since like we not mentioned that write
is closer to like sort of a record level
right we also support an avro based
format which is like row level
so um for for like sort of fast
ingestion and
logging sort of models we have avro and
then
uh we we support like parquet um
for any columnar performance although we
our log itself is designed in a way that
you could
log uh sort of park a bits also at like
you know smaller like granularity which
makes it closer to
uh a row level from like right but
that's something that we're still
working on
how to model parquet so that then the
readers
would get direct uh you know columnar
uh performance read uh even if you're
doing
very very closer to like row level
rights
so we have another question from andrew
um since you brought up the the merge on
read tables before
andrew is asking can you do incremental
queries on merge on read tables
yeah we we just added support uh so we
always had incremental
uh readers for hive we added that for
spark
and presto as well presto
it's not yet there it's in the works
so uh so the one qualification is this
works on
spark sql as an expired through hive
metastore
uh the next release we will have a
native
native support for incremental queries
on mor
just using spa you know the the data
source
format basically uh the two ways to use
uh spark right one is spark dot read dot
format hoodie
so that doesn't have more incremental
support yet
uh there's a pr open i think you will
just land in the next
increase but it works through other two
modes
and another question from rena since
we're taking questions
at the moment um every time i write
something new to my hoodie table
a new file version appears i thought of
limiting it to just one version
but how will this affect my point in
time queries
uh i think uh did you want to take that
sure i mean uh so if they are performing
upserts uh on to the data and you are
using
sort of copy on right to create your
file versions uh
then you would have to keep the number
of file versions if you want to go back
in time
um there are ways to
produce we have we have something called
save points uh
which you know if you don't want to uh
keep all
versions of the data from like say point
a
a time a to time b you can say i want to
save point my data at time a
delete all the intermediate versions and
then have the latest data
so you could do that for as an
optimization if you you know care about
storage space but
time traveling and point in time queries
also come at a cost of storage so
that's that's kind of the trade-off that
i've
so one thing i would like to add even
for non snapshot queries like you know
not the point in time queries about file
retention is
we also keep the files around
for like 10 10 hours or some time based
interval
that is tunable but this is done because
uh
all the engines basically like presto
ohio spark just materialize the plan up
front
so like let's say you have a long high
query which is running for four hours
you wrote a like a commit and you
produced a file
the high query started running on that
right and then if you
produce new versions in in the next one
hour and delete that
original version the hybrids will
eventually fail
right because it cannot find the
original file because that's how
high materializes the plan or like any
other engine up front
this is something that we would like to
be
fixed in the query engines lazily so
that they can pick the latest version of
a given file group or something but for
now
that's not how they work so we also keep
the files around for this purpose
like the the i think the default is
based on kind of what we ran at uber
which was
maximum timeline for a high query was 12
hours so we keep the file around for 12
hours
otherwise you'll just be frustrated by
high queries failing
like it is failing and coming back and
reading and failing and coming
this is like another another interesting
kind of thing that
jumped out and it shows how ingrained
this whole ecosystem was
to the fact that files don't change
so uh we got a couple more questions
this is great
is spark 3.0.0 supported
that's something that we are working on
right now it will be available in the
next release
this uh yeah there's a pr open we need
to certify
it it'll great
um andrew padilla is asking any
experiments
on how persistent memory may improve the
performance of hoodie
no what we would like to hear from you
if you
can run those experiments and just you
know come on and join
the you know we really love these kind
of like discussions in the community but
yeah great um
andrew that's a call out to you and to
anyone else in the community
who wants to contribute to the project i
know that vanoth and nishith are always
bugging me for contributors so now i'm
bugging you
here live so that uh you can all throw
your hat in the ring and help make this
project even more awesome
yeah how about
um no no go ahead go ahead
it's a great time to start contributing
as well there's like some
like a really interesting road map ahead
uh you know
how there are some like pretty like
fundamental things that we're also
working on um see so you know you get to
contribute to some fundamental aspects
of the project um so i would say it's a
great time to
start contributing that's great
um and i know there's there's folks in
the community that are aware of
um some other seemingly overlapping
projects
um someone's asking about iceberg
and um how you might compare contrast
with iceberg so
perhaps it's worth mentioning um you
know since
obviously it's important for you to
continue to get
contributions from the community um you
want to be able to articulate to folks
like why they would choose hootie over
some other project um like how would you
how would you phrase that like what's
most meaningful or what's most unique
about
or who is that compared to iceberg not
that one is you know better or worse but
um we know as engineers that we're
always making trade-offs and
optimizations
um so how do you think um who do you
might compare or contrast with
um other the projects that are out there
doing apparently similar things
so uh maybe i'll i'll start with an
answer based on
where things are today because like all
these projects are kind of like
like work and flight they're moving very
quickly so it's kind of like very hard
to have the conversation about like what
each project could build
but right now like hoodie is a great
choice for you
if you have um you know uh insertion
updates
um and you want to actually you know
build incremental data pipelines
and hoodie does a lot of things uh
so iceberg as i understand it is is kind
of like a table format
uh just like park a is a file format
iceberg is a table format which gives
you
ways to write to a table and then like
manage metadata on the table
iceberg has solved some very good uh
problems around
on the query side uh like file listings
uh and also um you know like column
column pruning stuff uh from from what i
can read
and so right now if you think about it
uh hoodie offers a lot of the
capabilities for you to write data very
well
while giving you out of the box kind of
query sub like query performance that
your
apache spark or apache hive and like
presto
give you out of the box while iceberg
gives you a table format
and uh like ways to efficiently like a
layer a metadata layer on top
which helps you you know maybe use
icebergs query
uh engines to kind of like read uh
the queries in a more optimized way
right so
that that's how the two projects stand
uh at this point
uh like hoodie obviously like
the alluding to the question before
right to solve upsets and deletes we
needed to solve transactions and
we needed to solve that table format
problem as well so
foodie internally has its own table
format like in
in a way like way it represents metadata
where it writes
uh files and reads files right so
but we also have built a lot of
machinery around
the file like the table format like for
example
if you know the snapshots in the date
table
you still have to write code to kind of
diff these snapshots
and build a cleaning algorithm which can
like
like remove older snapshots in the table
and things like that right
so hoodies kind of build with all these
bells and whistles bundled in
um down the line uh it actually
you can actually conceive maybe iceberg
as a
table format supported underneath woody
if you can abstract and make it work
uh in in that way um but these are like
very
very early thoughts i don't want to
promise anything
uh but that's how i i would i position
both with the
both the projects uh per se uh yeah
i think um and uh you know just like
what
mentioned i think the the writer part is
like you know like
the way we approached 3d when we
actually developed it was like
we wanted to get these massive amounts
of data so
we like we've solved the writer part
really well
uh right and and we've obviously had to
lay out the data because
we always have this there's always a
straight up of how fast you can guess
how fast you can query
can they both be in similar formats etc
so we've solved the aspects of how fast
can we just how can we do that trade-off
and and and i think iceberg is sort of
saying okay i can
manage this data after you've written it
um and
and and you know can both of them sort
of like overlay each other it's like
something that i think we know to talk
about
gonna get like some of the like the like
similarish features like uh
file listing um and
mostly because we can actually do it
very cheaply
easily because we already have a log of
all the changes and that's kind of like
battle tested for over the years in
reality why we didn't do that was mostly
uber specific
uh reasons where uber was running hdfs
right and if you we decided to scale
this metadata layer of the hdfs layer
rather than
investing in the layer above and
like can kind of like you know forcing
everyone to use the same
data library maybe there are people who
don't want to write
using uh hoodie for that data set right
uh a lot of like you know non-parking
data as well
so general that problem was solved at a
more hdfs level that we
just didn't get funded uh
early on basically but now i think with
a lot more users
adopting it on s3 and like cloud storage
this is like a problem that comes up and
then we
like we already are testing like uh some
solution around that
all that said in the spirit of like kind
of open source and community
i would love there to be like clear
kind of like you know um like scope for
each project uh in in some sense so that
contributors who are spending
like their volunteer time extra time
like how we are spending building the
project
can actually be efficiently like you
know contribute
focus their time towards like one
project like in some sense right
uh that's that's kind of how how
i for the broader interest of the the
open source community i think
yeah it probably you know make sense to
have at least
uh all the platform components that we
have maybe work on both formats but
but i think some of these problems will
get solved anyway
great um another question from
andrew he's asking how are the merge on
reed compaction scheduled
um so uh so that's configurable
um so there are different strategies
that you could choose to
you know figure out what is the
compaction that you want you could have
an i o based compaction you can have
like a partition based compaction uh
you could choose a time based compaction
so there are different strategies that
are supported
um uh the there is a automatic spar
uh compaction scheduling mechanism so i
think there is a spark structured
streaming model which
you can use to have like you know
long-running job which can
automatically schedule compactions based
on the strategy that you define
or you can schedule them like manually
uh via your ingestion job and then have
an asynchronous
compaction job sort of compact this
based on the strategies
and the the strategies can be like
broken down
so you can have multiple asynchronous
compactions running
a hoodie is designed in a way that with
using mvcc you can have multiple compact
so if you want to so at uber for example
we compact latest data quickly
uh and then older data more slowly uh
because we don't care so much about the
old data um
being uh you know available in next
let's say columnar format so that's how
we
deploy it um and like you could choose
anyone any strategy and deploy it
great so um we're almost out of time
guys but i
i wanted to ask you um speaking of the
future of the project
and sort of what's coming around around
the pipe um
what are you most excited about in terms
of the upcoming
road map for hoodie yeah so i think as
we don't mention like a couple of things
that are like
uh imminently like being worked on is uh
file listing
so where uh you know since hoodie was
designed on hdfs
we thought we had ways to scale it that
way but it seems like there are other
systems like s3 which are designed
differently
uh at least as of as as far as on my way
and certain specific scenarios so
uh in our next release we are sort of
eliminating file listing
um right and and the other thing that
we're working on is
um so as you can imagine you know as
you're ingesting large amounts of data
you're trying to tune it for skill uh
but you know
as users you know read this data that
that
pattern changes over time um and you
know to understand how to
lay out your data based on access
pattern um
is is sort of something that like we're
working on so there's this project
called clustering
where we could move around the data
based on
query access pattern to make it more
efficient
and then i know there there's like
strong community support to
like refactor some other things to bring
kodi on flink and then there are
a couple of other things i think we know
you may also want to add there
yeah so the other part is uh the
i think on similar lines as the listing
problem right
which is uh right now we have an
indexing mechanism which uses
uh we actually have a few ways of
indexing indexing is basically trying to
save and upsetting
this given record you want to quickly
figure out which file it dirties
basically
uh so we have like a version with hbase
uh that we deploy uh use our outside for
people who have a headspace
key value store right we have a built-in
one that is based on
join uh that we launched in point six
called simple indexing
we also have one which is based on bloom
index
um bloom filters some kind of range
information about the keys
uh that outperforms uh like a simple
join based
uh kind of you know indexing mechanism
that you find and
say delta or something or the simple
indexing itself
for kind of changing fact tables but
the one problem that we've had is say
you have a user's table
and then like it randomly gets updated
uh none of these are very efficient
the hbase index can perform very well
but you need hbase
so we are also working on like a record
level indexing mechanism
which can actually give you maybe like
uh you know close to uh hbase's
performance uh for for random
lookups um and then this
this we believe can be like a
fundamentally
uh new feature in hoodie um that can
solve
the the one class of use cases for which
there isn't a good solution out there
today
and by way of doing that the other
problem is the existing bloom index
um like we store the key ranges in part
k file footers
so we are also thinking about building
as
like a separate range index out
just like the record index and
which which can actually be used to
quickly prune files based on
key ranges and this will also be exposed
to
the query engine kind of like side
in a subsequent release uh the next
points on release will have these
features
and we are very very excited about about
these and
the the very cool thing that's happening
out there in the code right now is we're
refactoring the code
so that all of these are built as like
internally as
other hoodie tables so we are also in
some sense we
we might get multi-table transactions as
well because we need
the mechanism to keep the data the
package data table
and all these like metadata and like
index tables in sync
so we have to solve that problem and we
we have a like
those are the the core areas of focus
uh and of course like people are working
on jdbc
uh you know like at the the platforming
level right
the outside we're working on uh jdbc
uh incremental pulling so that you don't
have to run a scoop and then run delta
streamer you can just like run delta
streamer and pull from
uh jdbc kind of tables and we are trying
to improve schema evolution for the
kafka
connectors and like a lot of like
ingestion law will probably add
uh be working on like hardening the
the bulk bulking port
injection tool lot more and then the one
other thing that the major feature that
we introduced in 0.6 was the ability to
kind of bootstrap an existing parquet
data set as a hoodie data set
with the indexing and the incremental
without losing any functionality
basically
and we i think it's kind of like
experimental
even though we like you know for we want
to take few users and kind of harden it
over
and that again
is a very practical way for you to adopt
hoodie at a large scale for your entire
data lake
because you can run keep your old data
set and then
you can you need not copy data around to
build the new hoodie data set
uh you can keep the old pipelines
running
uh as long as you don't delete the
original files right hoodie will just
keep
work of a snapshot of your old data and
then
you can now count verify your booty
table and your old table
and you decide to cut over when you can
right so
that is a thing that we see we are
seeing a lot of large users who are
moving entire platform like the data
lakes over to hoodie
those users need a lot more uh
tooling on this side like mechanism for
them to be able to
go you know convince their management
that hey
i'm like trusting all our data with this
thing
and i can recover it i can still run
both the pipelines and validate the data
is good and all of that stuff right
these are like
uh we're also planning to like harden
that lot more
and then it will be the supported way
to like you know kind of like bring big
new hoodie data sets we are hoping
well those are a lot of exciting changes
um
coming down the road so we'll look
forward to that um
just as a sign off question i'm curious
to know from you guys
what what was the most surprising thing
you learned
as engineers either about the way people
use the tool we respond to the tool
about yourselves um what's the most
surprising thing that you learned
through this project
sure i think um i think i briefly
touched upon it like
the initial surprising thing for me is
like okay like you know
why isn't anybody solving it but i think
the the more surprising thing was the
way we started okay we
we want to solve this problem but it's
just amazing to see
how the community has grown and korea is
helping solve many other data
application problems we didn't touch
upon them for example machine learning
and
uh you know like we are like these are
like things that we
we never at least i never expected and
at least when we were building it out
and like the number of data applications
now using it
um are like many many like disparate
type of applications that was like
kind of the most like um surprising as
well as gratifying
uh that's rewarding for sure
for for me i think it's similar kind of
sentiment i i'm
just surprised that uh in a way like
invisibly that how
how broadly applicable this
uh this kind of like going back to that
blog right
how true that remains even today and
then how broadly it's become applicable
i remember telling initiative when like
we were like was first like you know
kind of joining the project that hey
look like either this is this thing is
going to like change how we do data
processing like in a fundamental level
or it will at least be a good way to
build incrementally in just databases
either way it's a fun problem that we
can put on our resumes
but yeah that that's the part that
really surprised us
on a more inward looking not um
for personally for me um i think
the the first year of building hoodie
from 2016 to
you know 17 right the headwinds uh just
for me personally
like going building something that was
very kind of thought very anti-pattern
at that time
um i think what i realized was after
it took me a little bit while to come
out of that i i
questioned myself a lot more about hey
am i actually like doing something more
complicated
uh where it shouldn't be uh like the the
the this whole uh file listing column
index thing is a great example we have
that idea
we still have the design dark and uber
from 2017
we didn't do it because we thought okay
like this is already a large change
and let's see people first like adopt
that
and we go forward but in retrospect i
felt like
yeah that's the one takeaway i have is
like i should like you know
trusted my instincts maybe a little bit
more and just keep grounding on
technical facts
uh i that's that's one learning
personally i had a
as a growth moment through this yeah
i would completely agree with that same
here well that's exciting because
um it's it's really a little bit like
building a company
right um as a founder who has built
engineering tools before i know
like how important it is to get adoption
and to have people get excited about
the paradigm that you're using to
explain the problem or the solution
and so um you guys were fortunate that
you were
able to see traction um even in you know
and with your crazy ideas
if you will um you know early on and so
that sort of gave you some function to
to continue
um to go down that road and to continue
to expand on those ideas so
um congrats for getting this far um it's
great to see who
we really progress and i hope that you
get some contributors
um and some users out of this
conversation so thanks for joining us
guys i really appreciate it
thanks for having us these are really
great questions and like yeah i really
really appreciate it
yeah this was a fun conversation thank
you so much thank you
so um i just want to end by mentioning
also our thanks to ibm who is a sponsor
of this episode
and ibm is a supporter of the open
source community
and they invite you to check out their
data science community
a link to which we'll put in the chat
you can check
that out for online resources content
and support for data professionals
also if you don't mind please share a
bit of feedback with us
in the forum that's also posted in the
chat it helps us
improve dc thursdays it helps us know
what you want to hear about
um it it really is an inspiration to us
as we continue to do these episodes for
the benefit of the community
and um i wanted to mention that our next
guest
on september 10th will be wes mckinney
who's
the author or co-author of the apache
arrow project
so we're really looking forward to
having wes and you'll be seeing more
details
from us in the future in the coming
weeks but mark your calendars for
september 10th
for our next dc thursdays with wes
mckinney